we'll talk about that stuff yo ya
welcome welcome you guys this is some
pipe this is yo all right all right
first off we some caffeine so let's go
I'll go into the fridge one of the
common fridge you know I get real hype
to this [ __ ] this is amazing product
launch we're launching a USB the a two
mini beat no no no not don't worry I
wouldn't launch that what's up uh sure
bro a sure bio what's log - well log -
in base - I believe is 1 because 2 to
the 1 is 2
alright we don't have any to give Benny
got T alright we got some some pure leaf
tea Antonio I didn't ignore you Andi is
not here welcome welcome welcome
alright what's Ln - I don't know that
[ __ ] pod C so if he is uh know what he
is he is like - I'm not gonna embarrass
myself I'm just gonna import numpy MP
dot ye yeah 2.7 all right I was gonna
say - poison that's embarrassing that I
don't know what he is by pi 3.14159265
three five nine seven nine i let's go we
are in general with the YouTube yeah
well in general with the YouTube what's
the news we got news today
we got news today yo Chris you want to
hit that button
do it alright alright ah
oh that's a product you can't show you
that was the derivative of e to the X
the derivative the e to the yes I
believe is e to the X and the integral
of e to the X is also e to the X that's
why you the X is so awesome everybody
should use they'll use and not rail use
all right we're just gonna give everyone
a minute to come in here we're at a
hundred people that's nice got this on
Twitter let's put that on Twitter we
don't want anybody to miss anything
drink some tea we got it we got to be
calm I know I know it's exciting let's
go dark now let's go oh what are my
nicest sweat pants today I got my hyung
guy with small park not r lu lu is
better than Relius nice and smooth no
sometime you want values but envision
bottles all you seem to work better at
you to test one of those that's why we
use L using our vision well and really
using our heads G on guys are great but
guys this what if it doesn't even have
to do with young guy what if you all got
tricked you know and we're launching
commas sneakers what's happening this
dream we're launching products and
there's an S on there it's plural def
cons cancel don't know y'all who wants
to have Underground Def Con we'll call
it make dep come on cool again i'll put
it on all right you guys some CPF
problems will be sick make def con cool
again
sneakers yeah yeah grats would be
profitable thank you thank you
we're actually last month was not
profitable off our obvious reasons we
don't have to discuss but this month
we're looking profitable again we hired
a great production engineer we're gonna
go back we're gonna look at the
production facilities a bit today it's
gonna be pretty good idea oh my favorite
artists don't know any artists
who's a great artist uh artist Elon Musk
Hawkman um what's my opinion the lottery
cake in hypothesis this is a nice dream
oh man I forgot the s in the plural all
right what we're gonna go to the title
guy and we're gonna give the title guy a
week of unpaid time off cuz you did a
bad job on the title uh no I didn't
watch new Elon and Joe Rogan uh Banksy
I've heard a Banksy I don't know who
else who else a visual art visual arts
kind of hard these days who do I like
the world is a beautiful place I'm no
longer afraid to die there are artists
shinigami
I listen to who was it the Dixie Chicks
song this morning it's pretty good
they're Philosopher's plane each a you
choose like it got look you feel like
you feel like a certain like when you
read it you know you feel like you feel
like strong and powerful and then you
read Heidegger and you're like what's
this guy saying I have no idea man being
in time is going surpassing Python in
the future I don't know why not make it
a lot easier for people flying open
pilot what do you say what are you
saying what do you want make a PR and
get hub that's what I like to hear
that's the way to interact that is the
future um
you believe in something what do you
believe in whoa whoa whoa panel who's
heard of the pan of Jumonville all right
all right I think it's I think it's time
let's get that up there let's get the
view count up to up to 200 and then and
then we'll really start um this stuff
out
oh yes yes we are looking good where is
your order it should have definitely
shipped all right where are 200 people
let's go
so we're gonna start with a cute little
product we're gonna start with our
smallest of the products xx xx 9 7 9
Hyundai bro absolutely but we're not I
do love you back but this isn't your
dock this whoa Hyundai car harness whoa
whoa whoa what are you guys doing whoa
we're starting with this it's really
small so I'm gonna bring it nice and
close to the thingy so you guys can see
it you see this this is a comma key okay
so use your story you adventure it off
of release - you wanted to try the
latest mods you are cutting edge so
cutting edge in fact that you bricked
your comet oh you can brick to coma - if
you're right bad panda firmware um but
no fear if you have a comma key a comma
key makes your comma - almost
unbreakable if you really do bad stuff
you can still technically break it you
can fix it if you take it apart but this
makes your comment to effectively
unbreakable all you have to do take your
comma key plug it into the back of your
car - right there and then when you hold
this button down the Panda goes into DFU
mode so this is a comma key there are 99
dollars and they're available right now
at shop.com Adani I slash products right
here with a nice little story apparently
they only have one picture this is a
comma key
yeah $99 damn I know yet comma keys are
expensive but you know do you want to
solder all those little tiny USB shits
no you don't so that's a comma key a
comma key is like a panda pull off but
it's for the comma - and also
potentially
for future products with the Obi DC
connector how does the comment get power
with the key you just plug it in right
here you plug in a second USB over here
so I can just plug this guy in right
here and there you go yes small price to
pay if you brick it alright so that's a
comm this is just a normal comma - let's
move on to our next product and that's
right over here this product here is the
Panda jungle alright so we've had to
build you know what maybe before we
announce the jungle we're gonna go take
a lot a look it's $2.99 it's $2.99 it's
a good price let's go take a look at
some stuff that we've built yeah yeah
we're on we're on live stream right now
yeah iced coffee alright welcome oh
they're gonna boot up now welcome we
have 272 people all right but I'm just
showing off the jungles aren't they
ready to go
all they're firing up right now there's
gonna be cool this is how we test the
comet ooze before we send them to you
they're actually really well tested now
and each comma two is powered back here
by a pain panting rig oh yeah yeah 12
one you want to show them the power
supply yeah we to put heavy gauge wires
for each panda because they were
overheating you couldn't burn your
fingers on the water that's a nice thick
wire yeah all right so we're connecting
to them right now
yeah they're all gonna start right now
this is what you can do with your panda
jungle this is what's possible if you if
you write a lot of code oh wow that's
crazy
floor gang
yeah floor gang yeah so they just they
just will come up and test all through
the convenient panda jungle which can be
yours for the low price of $2.99 let's
go take a look at it oh by the way also
we sold a thousand pandas to an unnamed
buyer for 69 thousand dollars they're
purchasing a Killa panda or first ever
kill a panda so that's boxed up ready to
go the other bit of exciting news is if
you buy a comet to see these comma twos
they are unclaimed one of these can be
yours right now we have 40 in stock
ready to ship on Monday so now is the
perfect time to buy a comet - and
there's gonna be many more comet oohs
where that one came from as you can see
by we are the world's largest
refurbisher about Lego phones yeah so
that is that let's go back to our
computer and let's take a look at the
other product all right go back to shop
here scroll down go to the developer
shop down here you'll find the Panda
jungle what's better than a debug board
pandas in a jungle by the way you can
plug in up to six comma twos in one
panda jungle one two tres cuatro Cinco
seis that's a crazy amount so you can do
that with oh and the jungle is of course
for sale for two hundred and ninety-nine
dollars so so far we've announced the
comma key right here perfect for
breaking your comma - if you do stupidly
brick it and also the Panda jungle
you're about to buy a comma -
congratulations now is absolutely the
time to smash that Buy button get a
comma - you'll be like wow I bought a
comma - I'm so happy all right how many
jungles can you run in series as many
jungles as you can buy
we're running a whole wooden rack full
of jungles that that's a whole like I
don't even know man that's a whole South
America back there all right so let's
plug this wire in
I don't know what a GI means what's the
common jungle I'd say the Panda jungle
super exact it's a great way to power
your , - indoors it's not a very
expensive way you'd have to make sure
that switch yeah there's also a switch
to gate the power and you can see that
it's booting out so there we go the
Panda jungle can you connect a jungle to
a jungle absolutely you can connect a
jungle to a jungle six times actually
this is the control port for the jungle
which you can connect to a computer the
jungle has basically a panda on board
we're gonna open source the firmware
probably later today maybe Monday all
right has fork and buses on it it has a
panda it's got some nice voltage
regulator you can trigger ignition here
it's got some some LEDs that show you
yes we shipped to India we ship
everywhere the common jungle looks so
nice
panda jungle buy your panda jungle right
now
okay 324 people let's let's take a
minute and let's go through our white
board I cleaned off things that were
secret on the white board notice that
that secrets have been removed but kana
has come a long way and you know we
really appreciate having all of you here
on the journey with us
they bought white pans they bought a lot
of white pan is one of our goals is
million dollar July you guys will be
hearing a lot more about million dollar
July you know this is the other this is
the other crazy thing notice how our
competition is wilting look at Zuke's
right okay I'm not talking about the
competition we're talking about open
pilot 1.0 look at all these things
I'm talking about all of this stuff
level 5 platform profitable q3 and q4
noted failure of others disengagement
analysis you do all the things that
we're gonna buy with all our crazy new
amount of money
well timeline for the common three no
one said anything about the combi three
though there is one other big product
announcement there is one other big
product announcement today but we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna can we get to 350 people before we
do the next product announcement Oh a
six might happen a lot of stuff might
happen
grown-up comment your recent job
interview and murders that a good thing
that a good thing I don't know can't
tell but this is a comic key if you guys
don't have a comic key you can buy one
for 99 dollars this is a pan of jungle
you guys don't have a pan totally you
can actually order it right now let's
see if anybody's ordered any of this
stuff murder killed in a good way oh
that's great that's great
yo wood sale
those are going crazy waste sales are
going crazy how many pandas and jungles
have we sold that's all I'm interested
in right now pandas and jungler I don't
think we've sold any pandas and jungles
oh you just bought back oh whoa whoa I
don't know where you heard about that
alright we're almost at 350 people this
here is the key to my Hyundai Sonata
I've been driving it
shonda's are going to be the best car
for open pilot and in order to support
that we're launching the Hyundai harness
now now you say oh this is a harness how
exciting could that be gross the shunned
eye harness is actually five harnesses a
B C D and E and there's an F G and H
coming soon that aren't ready because
Hyundai is a terrible manufacturer and
makes every harness different yeah so if
you have an a harness you need this one
B harness you need this want to see
harness don't worry this is conveniently
done with our compatibility flow and I
bring you live
[Laughter]
so there's some fun as that will just
work out of the box right it's not a
2020 it's supported community supported
by the combat to no issue you there but
the hardware teams done great job
checking a bunch of these different cars
like this is a giant list of all these
cars will be checked so let's say we
wanted to get a coda harness you'll get
the second screen that says is your
probably built in em with camera you're
gonna say yes and there's a smooth page
that's likely candidate and just because
it's not supported by open pilot yet
doesn't say community support it but we
still do sell the harness so you could
click buy it adds the right harness to
your cart we have we have the ones we
have the ones in bold that are yeah yeah
we can go through this that's pretty
good so wow this is we should we should
uh we should open source us yeah yeah
yeah we get we got to do this cuz this
is confusing [ __ ] scroll down and there
are some available here as well as some
Kia's wow this is getting so long Wow
look at all those Wow yonder ice and
then wait someone was asking about the
Sonata 2019 oh but it is supported by
any yeah so if you do it you'll just get
out tell you what jungling TR if you
don't understand what the jungling key
are they aren't for you should we look
at this - yeah sure so I'm gonna post
this in the discord this just shows this
type yeah 1 2 and s which is a so either
your connector look at what wires are in
it and you'll know what Wow as well so
that's gonna go out in the discord for
people who want to check what car they
have yeah we should actually do want to
write a medium post with like links to
these things talking about what a pain
he Hyundai is and maybe encouraging
to change I already own a comma to
Hyundai e is not listed on the car
harness shop page so go to the car
harness oh yeah by the way
wait no no not car scroll down go to
harness connector yeah by the way we've
raised the price of the harness
connector to $100 oh wait no it's not
here no it's not gonna be here you can't
get the very bottom oh I see
so any car that's unsupportive you can
still select at the bottom
Hyundai II development wow that's the
biggest pain yes biggest pain Wow shunda
is the worst alright a dandy you just
make sure it works cuz some guys said it
didn't work alright
yo Hyundai II wait is that also at the
bottom of the car harness so if you go
back to okay I don't make sense
cool you can of course buy that with a
black panda if you want that too but
yeah the Hyundai is not look at this
look guys who wouldn't do this why did
they do this you know the comet team has
been working really hard to make this
possible for you guys yeah let's let's
just link those resources in discord now
if you guys are not in our discourse at
discord comedy I yeah well so we'll
start with that picture and then medium
poster be nice the difficulty of the
Hyundai harness I think that's a great
medium post people know that we put a
real effort into that and that's why all
the stuff is uh so he's been soo don't
hate me see away from comma pencil well
yeah I mean you know come on pencils
very important but beyond i harnesses
bring in money and we love money so yeah
we need win that win that money so you
guys should buy those giant eye
harnesses I heard about wonderful
I heard wonderful things about you know
how many people were gonna buy this so
I'm really hoping for everybody to come
to come by this
you guys have choices you can buy an a
you can buy a B or you can buy a see you
can buy a D or you can buy an e the
discount code for the live stream is you
better buy one of these before they run
out do you think we're keeping five
things in stock that's a crazy amount of
things that's as many fingers as I have
and just wait'll we launch F G and H
we're gonna have to get into toes just
kidding I know I have ten fingers all
right what else we got what else we got
that's most of the stuff we had planned
for today we're gonna go to 30 minutes
here oh man I've been playing around go
commas trying to become a we're trying
to get the comma twos to have custom
comma IME eyes let's see how my new
models coming along the models coming
along okay losses going down that's good
any extra if you call all right all
right all right I guys we're gonna do it
I'm gonna make a discount right now this
was not part of any plans but I'm just
gonna make a discount for you guys are
you guys ready for the discounts all
right all right the discount code is
gonna be lucky yeah I'll do it right
here okay the discount code is going to
be live stream one and it's gonna be a
fixed amount and it's gonna save one
dollar if you know the code live stream
one $1 off your entire order and you can
only of course use this once per
customer no limit the number of times
okay you know what we're only gonna have
no no no no no no no I think everybody
can use this and we're gonna have it go
for the next hour let's say everybody
who gets in during the live stream you
guys can use the code live stream one to
get one dollar off your entire order
that's how generous we are common not a
I hear you guys save $1 right now smash
that Buy button you'll never get it
cheaper than right now save $1 until
3:00 p.m. so it ends it ends at 3:00
p.m.
one dollar you guys can save a dollar
you guys can go donate your dollar to
Doctors Without Borders or something or
whatever you want to donate your dollar
to but it's one dollar off the entire
order for everyone let's see how many
people are gonna start to use this
amazing discount code
let's get these orders and I don't know
what Mahindra Scorpio is save a dollar
everybody save a dollar I'm gonna go get
those hair dye harnesses so I can I can
caress them while we have more
livestream
yeah harnesses alright let's go over
quickly
everything that we launched in today's
livestream yeah save the dollar yeah all
right
who's spamming hit is spamming you are
in timeout Mahindra Scorpio I don't know
what that is you're in timeout
okay we have the type a horn is the type
B horn as well this is so much stuff
this is so much stuff how many people
right now I've saved the dollar you
better get that order and fast should I
put a limited number of dollars that can
be saved
Wow nobody's using it we need we need
some thought we come on spend some money
we got we got eleven orders today
already all of this stuff ships all this
stuff ships Monday so when you guys get
your order in ships by Monday talk to
your dad right now spend your stimulus
check this is a great place to spend
your stimulus check well that's some
delicious tea this is a delicious jungle
okay well we have one last jungle now it
was delicious was the best $299 I ever
spent
yes oh so is that here's economy key I
don't want to have another jungle right
here wins Volkswagen harness you guys
you guys we make something for you and
you just ask when's next we make
something amazing for you Hyundai
harnesses look look at the detail that
goes into this it's like that's the
connector
that's crazy stuff Dada Dada it's got a
type s connector what is the comma key
for if you break your comma - you can
unbreak it with a comma key thank you
thank you give you a shout out I'll give
you a shout out if you use the discount
code whose use the discount code
livestream one all right you know what
we want to incentivize some people to
provide some stuff so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna whoa wait people
didn't even use the code but we got new
orders where we're at 14 orders now
that's crazy
okay should we increase the discount you
place the order can you get $1 back if
you contact support bro bro no you order
before discount all right all right all
right all right all right we'll give
everybody we'll give everybody $1 off
but there's a $5 support fee I like that
you know what buy a meeting
you're just use the discount code wait I
don't know maybe this is just broken it
says zero use but I think it's just
broken cuz we now have 15 orders yeah I
don't know maybe Shopify is just broken
yo discount you get a dollar off
anything $1 off your entire order if
you'd like your if you'd like the
discount code retro actively added to
your stuff might I recommend purchasing
a meeting and we can do that so for
$1,000 you can buy a meeting you can
also save a dollar on the meeting if you
proceed to checkout and you use this
great discount code oh may 500 meetings
not a valid discount code anymore but if
you use the discount code livestream one
you can save $1 that's crazy that's
crazy that's the biggest savings we've
offered in a long time
II see B
ah D and a get the whole family in here
like alphabet soup
the shirts are sold out your shirts sold
out wait we sold out of shirts Nick we
sold out of shirts some sizes Wow
we gotta get some more shirts we do what
you say oh yeah I don't know about that
I don't know if we're gonna get that
crazy nice bag look at these we're now
filtering out comma two is that overheat
stress test failed look those ones fail
we take him out we don't ship them to
you comma twos are the highest quality
they've ever been if you're thinking
about buying a comma two with the crazy
one you know I offered a $1 discount yet
live stream one oh nice sweet sweet
goodbye Paul wait they got a $19 Paul
that's too cheap oh well okay
5% discount what do you think this is
you save a dollar be happy you're
googled what's up a hindrance Corp yeah
oh it's a cool car all right um these
are more testings I kill a panda you
know did you know you could put metric
prefixes before pandas bring back the
comma vini where apparently a - from
shirt sizes we're gonna get more shirts
in one of these days yeah these are our
values externalization sustainability
its ability and quality not growth and
not short-term profit million dollars oh
wow you guys have been hearing a lot
about that we're trying to shoot for
eight million in revenue in 2020 this is
how many years everybody thinks until we
get to level five self-driving so we got
225 s in there we got some twos and
threes and fours and fives
I was the eighth a Giga pant there are
tariffs and we don't have them any
pandas we don't even have a mega panda
how many comma twos are we shipping each
month now about 250 I'm more than that
actually that was last month it's about
500 now
yeah check it out
kama jungle help good is open pilot bro
I'm not convinced icky with [ __ ] you
don't know how good it is don't all buy
it when is nissan support coming
official we have nissan support up
streamed is 0.75 model fix you know we
have some issues with that model well uh
we're gonna do 0 7 5 next week to make
sure that comes out before the hyundai
oh whoa five people have used the
discount code I don't even know what's
going on Shopify is just weird five
people did you guys actually email
support so you can get it retroactive
Lee added your orders yeah um just for
the rest of this live stream you can use
the code livestream on if you don't
think $1000 is affordable might you
consider a Tesla we're full sub driving
costs is it seven thousand or you can
get a comet to for just $9.99 what a
crazy low price we point out how
beautiful comma twos are are they're so
beautiful
yeah nice support is already here he on
I support is already in master and we're
gonna ship that in zero 75 with chips
next week so if you order a Hyundai
harness right now by the time it gets to
you beyond I support will be in open
pilot um do we support the Russian
language we're working on multi Lang
multi Lang is a requirement for open
pilot one point out um what phone is
modified so it's it's not really a phone
anymore
we just like use the phone case and like
the phone motherboard but like it's not
it doesn't have a battery it has a
replacement front camera so we can see
in the dark it's kind of like a bunch of
phone parts you know what I mean Elan
built it what it was it what is it Tony
Stark built this in a cave with scraps
yeah bro by a comet oh another great the
testing has improved leaps and bounds so
if you buy a comma two today you're
getting one that went through a really
rigorous testing that's 24 hours of
non-stop perfection
how much longer will Yuans be supported
if you have a black Panda you'll get a
bit more out of it if you have a white
panda going away soon if you have a gray
panda results may vary depending on your
fingerprints if you have a Black Manta
it'll be well your black banner will
could use 40 out for a while but um yeah
before that you know it's been it's been
it's been almost a year now since we
launched the black panda play nine
months ah white panda we launched grey
pandas so long ago so white pandas are
going away well they'd be an affordable
calm assistance don't like to comment a
little and if you don't think the
comment to is affordable guess what I
have for you I have for you a sick
discount it's called live stream one and
you guys can get one dollar off your
entire order Aryan stop spamming five
people have already used this incredible
discount that let's let's just pretend
that you're buying a comet too
let's let's do that right now we'll take
out this sick discount code out of our
cart you're not gonna buy a meeting the
meetings are legitimately a scam don't
buy a meeting the meetings are just you
know it's kind of like but that's your
insult three meetings so why they bought
the pandas we don't ask those questions
we just sell we just sell okay ah let's
say I wanted to buy a comet - let's say
I'm buying it for my beautiful new
Hyundai Sonata 2020 which is really a
great car that's gonna be the top car
that's why it's the a harness by now it
doesn't ship with any software that's
fine I know where to get software we're
gonna here proceed to checkout and guys
it's never been cheaper right now to
purchase a comet - because I can use
this incredible discount code livestream
one and I can save one dollar you get
one dollar off a white panda you can get
one dollar off everything with that
discount code alright let's take a look
at some of our products oh this is a
black panda we have black pandas they're
in stock you don't really want one
because guess what's inside of a comet -
black
and technology that's right it's called
you know it's right here
GPS antenna inside the mount kama tombs
are incredible futuristic technology
that you'll only be able to find right
here at shop comma dot AI so you just
plug this guy into here this is the OB
DC connector in the comment who has one
wire it gets power any data over the one
wire then you'll plug that into your
convenient harness block which is
included with the purchase of a car
harness which you buy with your comma
two you just take that guy plug it into
there and then let's say I was getting
that twenty twenty Sonata so I have the
a harness right here I take the a
harness gives a nice satisfying click I
can write this all in my trim and that
lets my Hyundai Sonata experience most
incredible level to self driving this
side of autopilot and super cruise this
is a bomb your comments who broke when
you dropped it why'd you drop it
no okay oh and then you also need the
comma power so this here's a comma power
connects the Ethernet wire this provides
constant power your comma - which can
put it on the comma Connect app which if
you guys haven't read my medium
published you guys should go read my
medium polished about the time my car
got towed and I used to come and connect
I see Honda is getting super crazy I'll
believe that when I see it this is a
great excuse to buy another comma - with
a live stream one that's an incredible
idea I see how much money we've made so
far tonight how are we doing yeah that's
not that good that's not that good you
guys can do better you guys can do
better this is our total sales for the
day I believe in y'all you can do better
than that oh we sold two comic Keys
developer car harnesses those chun-tae
harnesses we got to start selling a man
you know what you guys are better than
Subaru people though right I believe in
you you guys buy a lot of counter
harnesses don't make me regret all the
absurd amount of work we went to to make
eight different types of Hyundai
harnesses yeah I think Oakland pilot
will get longitudinal control for the
count eyes we're working on that we're
pretty excited about that how can you
add a twenty twenty cent out of the car
just go to 2020 Sanada shows up his car
harness young guy a you don't need to
carry it in Wi-Fi you just get common
prime it's included three to three
months with the comma - I think the
power of the phone that there's so much
power in here guys it's been coated in
Python we'll just go to C++ free CPU
yeah I'm regretting the discount already
you know what you know what guys
discounts over discounts are you sure
you should have bought it sooner you
should have bought it sooner five people
got this incredible livestream one
discount but now the discount is over
delete discount oh we saw 10 Jedi
harnesses wait am I just not looking in
the right place well that's pretty
amazing we've really sold tenth hang on
yeah we bring that up I'm bringing it up
right now and chop fine let's do today
oh wait I think I was looking at the
wrong day uh car harness oh yeah whoa
yeah we're selling young guy bonuses
they're moving I mean I don't know how
you got ten or just say five I don't
even remember but we've already sold
five that's pretty good Wow so much
better the Subaru resold zero Subaru
harnesses we solve a two FCA harnesses
we're only halfway through this live
stream and Hyundai is already at full
arm you were gonna play with a $1
discount not anymore I'm sorry I'm sorry
you know you got to move fast if you
want to get that - all right we'll bring
back the discount all right all right
we're bringing the discount back all
right calm down
well I really just deleted that hard all
right all right I'll bring the discount
back all right all right I know I know I
know the only thing worse livestream the
only thing worse than missing out on a
discount is being so close I fixed
amount discount $1 applies to entire
order everybody's eligible and remember
it ends in just 25 minutes at 3:00 p.m.
$1.00 off the entire order livestream
won its back its back boys livestream
one Wow livestream one oh yeah let's
let's promote this yeah this is dill
oh I don't even know
guys this pretty good livestream thanks
for looking out for karma today's a
great day to buy with the $1 off
discount livestream one
oh well sessions are to the moon though
well there's seven people on the website
right now okay look it's sessions there
to the moon even know something
something weirds going on here eyes Ida
Pro running I'm working on something
hundred dollars off whoa what we never
do discounts like that we see you can
save $1 right now that's the best
oh yeah we're using the hexagon TSP to
around the driver monetary model which
runs this is a big picture of a comet to
see one of these guys as a camera the
top one that's a camera right there do
$3 yes you do you showed your discount
codes no we can go through the discount
cause I don't think any of them are that
good ah wait a second yeah some of these
are wait this just shouldn't be here
right yeah why are all these discount
codes still active whoa hang on
Wow there's all these secret discount
codes that were given to people Wow good
thing or they're limited no I think
these are mostly for so if you buy
things in bulk we'll hook you up with a
discount code if you want to buy more
than 10 of an item from the comma store
you can you know let's see last time
we've done like a real discount
oh we had discount code shirt discount
code sure it was pretty fast ah no I'm
not they're already all gone oh yeah we
sold two meetings with the meeting
discount code we sold one meeting
without a discount
um yeah but wow we haven't had our real
discount a real discount a wild yell
work for yah no for Labor Day Labor Day
was the last real discount yeah we
usually do Labor Day discounts hunter
dollars off get out of here with you
hundred dollars off oh wow no no we gave
him a dollar off they should be happy
with that
I put the discount go back it's only
till 3:00 p.m. if you email in later if
you email even before and say you want
the dollar and you ordered before 2:00
we'll give you the dollar but if you
order after three no dollar for you oh
we're done talking about discount codes
I know I had $100 code all active I
don't know how that got in there
all right it wasn't for it wasn't for
you I mean you can look at these codes
it barely been used by any buggin we're
done talking about discount codes but we
will quickly look at just count codes
like um so like you see these are like
one person discount codes they're not
like real the last legit discount code
we had was shirt or you could buy one
item and you would get a shirt that's
why we're out of shirts oh I regret
doing the discount so badly we're out of
shirts cuz we gave them all away for
super cheap we're using a resonable
using an efficient man that's even
better
I'm so save a dollar right now with this
town called live stream one this is a
comic jungle this is a comic e is a
panda jungle a comic e don't plug your
comic keys into here my short out your
gym wall they're designed to be plugged
into comma to who's like that you
beautiful look at this comet oh this can
be yours for the low price my hair looks
bad well you know guys there's a little
something going on right now it's a
little hard to get a haircut Oh big
models going pretty well stopping the
traffic lights kind of works there's a
comet to overheat not really sometimes
some people are experiencing overheating
where they leave their car out in the
Sun it takes like five minutes to cool
down we're working on that but it
doesn't overheat while you're driving
it's pretty quiet - yeah
alright let's take a deep breath let's
do a few questions well we just wait for
the sales to pour in and people to use
this incredible discount code livestream
or if you're interested in John dye
harness there's never been a better time
you can purchase this Hyundai harness oh
wow that's a lot of sales oh we have
that
we got a bunch of offices your back you
ordered a comic eat
excellent you're gonna love a common key
it's a great product chill meditation
stream Tama - yeah I don't know I mean
what else what else do you guys want to
see what is that what is the title about
today we've launched the Hyundai harness
all different kinds of Hyundai harness
just go to the website the compatibility
flow now works first ordered Hyundai
vehicles
yeah we launched the comma key which
allows you to unbreak - comma - like
conveniently plugging them in we have
the common jungle it works pretty I'm
Nydia and Genesis on forgetting things I
should tell these things these work for
Jean guys Kia's end Genesis's so if you
have a Hyundai or Kia or you happen to
live in Saudi Arabia and own a Genesis
these things are perfect for you
what are the best Hyundais I love my
2020 Hyundai Sonata it's really a great
car business is business is booming so
we made sixty nine thousand dollars
yesterday selling pandas we're hiring a
lot of people this year - welcome to the
big year of expansion you see this is
zukes this is calm okay so that's good
if you guys are interested comedy I
slash jobs we were a beautiful office
here in San Diego guys can come join
it's a nice office so nice forgive
everybody like you know how like the
tech companies are like cramming people
in and like you can little like you get
a little desk and a shared office we
have like a real nice like everyone is
like a hundred square feet of space
everyone's got lots of space what about
intern so new job posting for executive
assistant oh that's exciting um how many
employees now we're like 15 we have
interns how much is the rent section K a
month how is security considered what
how did you tow me into reading that um
this young guy have more steering torque
and Toyota it's similar
I haven't had torque problems yeah
it's a lot better than Honda I'll say
that well I pay for relocation yet we
have relocation bonuses
what about entry-level jobs not really
common to repair program if you're
competent broken they're all still under
warranty it's uh we have a one-year
warranty unless of course you like
dropped it we don't drop it
but yeah or we also have a 30 day no
questions asked money back guarantee on
anything bought in our store so if you
buy something you don't like it doesn't
work with your car just send it right
back
you own your money back um do you let
your employees anyone's welcome to work
from home but I don't know I mean I like
coming into the office
um is it made in America yeah it's been
right in the back it's made right in the
back down here in San Diego I swear
we're not Mexico um well don't make
false claims about coronavirus we'll get
booted off YouTube I need more data
scientists maybe then we don't like like
if you're just a data scientist probably
not but if you can code well and you
want to analyze data yeah yeah we got a
lot of data analytics we got to do we're
gonna be more globally targeted I don't
even know what that means you're the
same guy who asked about security
if you're looking for the executive
assistant job we're looking for people
with really like experience in that sort
of role we're trying to grow calm a lot
this year
like operationally we're trying to go to
20 people by the end of the year now is
a great opportunity you know guys you
know the old saying it's like step one
become worthy step 2 accept our step 3
rule we're still working on step 1
but step 2 has never looked more closed
so that's really exciting do we take
paypal maybe I'm not sure maybe you can
check out with PayPal flex raise over no
remote work yeah a flex rate flex rate
no flex right not gonna happen
doing accept Bitcoin no I don't think so
I just sell your Bitcoin and you know
buy it with a normal credit card
how about how are sales doing
24-hour bodyguard what mean no oppai CVE
if you can find bugs just file them on
issues if you have like a real security
issue you can email me um is there a map
of comma users we are everywhere Wow
total sessions you guys I see you on the
website I see you just thinking about
making up your mind about whether you
want to buy it for another 15 minutes
you can save $1 we're not hiring any
marketing people get out of here with
your marketing boo-boo marketing no flex
rate harness is not for sale
no we were we focus on like okay guys
just look come on our shopping you know
we'll go on the shop page we'll go we'll
do computer together go on the shop page
and I want you to look at how far we've
come you know so the what are the
peduncle and the key really the jungle
is really a replacement for the debug
board right compare this product which
is like three traces on a two layer
board to this crazy thing all right
like that's how far comm has come in the
last two years Mahindra Scorpio guys
back huh who's ever Manning the YouTube
can we can we can we can we yeah change
the order of the products yeah we might
we're gonna change up the store a lot I
think giraffes are going away
bye-bye giraffes nobody's gonna miss you
you were the shittiest product comment
ever made
alright Mahindra Scorpio is a funny joke
it's fine um you only said it once but
if you say it more than once
yeah the comic he compared the comma key
to the panda paw wow this is like some
like look at that look at this
engineering this is like look at look at
that caught on the board oh it's
terrible look at the comma key beautiful
it's beautiful is comma crime worth it
yeah kind of depends
guys how's that the undyed posting going
we have those who died things posted up
somewhere we only come back down Oh C or
D refer to the image I don't yeah
someone DM me and told me that I leaked
it one of the discount codes there was a
tiny minute when you could have saved
the hundred dollars with a discount code
and then we would have been validated
your order um can I share that sheet
yeah we're gonna share the sheet will
share the sheet when we're done are you
fund a great journey with Prime no prob
out like Prime is what it is it's an
unlimited the SIM card for your thing I
like it but I don't really care about
the money so you know but if you're
trying to like like penny pinch and save
money conference probably not ready yet
the big thing that's gonna complicado
prime is navigation so the real reason
that we smoke weed at the office what do
you think this is the what was I saying
I got distracted talking about the
Hyundai harnesses Oh navigation yeah
comma crime with navigation that's right
um if you have common prime you're gonna
need that in order to get navigation to
get navigated an open pilot navigate an
open file it's gonna be like a phone
comma experience it's gonna be pretty
cool and of course you know prices only
go up oh yeah we raised a price today we
raised a price today so we used to sell
these wires these harness connectors for
$50 they used to be only $50 but now
thanks to the insane complexity of
Hyundai we were actually losing money at
$50 so they're now $100 for all of them
you're not good at any of those can you
still get a job no best way is to close
this stream and purchase things with
discount code of life you want
ah thought it would be for Honda Hyundai
in that way we have great stuff for
Honda tab I don't care what degrees you
have you're gonna come in here and
you're gonna we're gonna ask the
following question do you say smart
things and you not say stupid things as
long as those two things are true you're
probably pretty good and you gotta know
things right so you know when I ask you
questions like what's the output space
for segments you better know right let's
categorical cross-entropy let's go let's
go
yeah following distance your following
distance is just social distancing for
your car's floor gang I believe before
game chill the floor for bed oh you
always playing with us playing with this
lady go yesterday no support for the
Mahindra Scorpio there are great offline
navigation apps why needing Kama Prime
no not for ours what it's gonna be
does the Kama to make sure you're paying
attention to the road yes it does yes it
does it has driver monitoring even at
night powered by infrared LEDs I'm
number one car makers you look at to get
the best experience right now the
out-of-the-box best experience is the
2020 Toyota Corolla though if you're
thinking for the future I have one we're
gonna work on it really hard the 2020
Hyundai Sonata is gonna be a great car
it's already supported right now for
long offer for lateral its longitudinal
policy is well it's better than Toyota's
let's just say that no navigation in
Europe then yeah probably America only
yes it watches the eyes and it watches
the head position
just calm primal our remote access come
two cameras on the vehicles parked
absolutely yes so that's that's in the
app when you click on the device it'll
take snapshots it's great you know my
car got towed a week ago and it was
great
get out of here with the hacking and
exploitation stuff that's not we're
talking about we're gonna talk about
Karma if you cover up the camera will
still work with steering wheel nudges
yes it will
yes if you really don't like driver
monitoring you can fall back to the the
Tesla like mode of nudging the wheel but
I think driver moaning is a lot better
yeah going in five weeks that's awesome
tell us about navigating on paths like
navigating on autopilot gonna be shitty
here for you everything we're gonna get
better than them because we're sick
crazy machine learning ideas that's
beyond the Tesla house does it check if
you are drunk don't drive drunk what
comments port traffic light recognition
that's the wrong way of thinking about
it will it stop at traffic lights that's
a better way of thinking about it think
end-to-end guys you got a thing for it
dimensionally yeah you're driving from
New York California enjoy man gonna be
fun drive traffic lights Awards comma
recognition that's enough talking about
right now that's stupid vehicle to
vehicle communication is extremely
stupid and vehicle to infrastructure
communication is only slightly less
stupid except that's what comma Prime is
so make sure to buy comma crime if you
have stuff alright for anyone just
joining the stream today we launched a
common jungle panda jungle panda jungle
is there a public road map you'll find
some stuff in the github if you look
around is driver monitoring video stored
in the TV not by default by default we
do not record it at all but you can opt
into an optional in settings but if you
just install it straight up now it's not
by default it's entirely local to device
what's virtually christine virtually
Christa's are head of communications he
is our head of communications who was
the worst employee you've ever had you
really think I'm gonna answer that I do
have one in mind um
did Andres talk prove to you that you
were ahead yeah yeah we're ahead of
Tesla machine right we're ahead of Tesla
machine learning Tesla is ahead of us
and hardware and obviously I have uh
safely ties Alex work at Commodore Alex
was a seasonal employee at comma oh by
the way you could also use your panda
jungle with a black panda or comma - you
get so many choices you can even go
crazy you know I don't know where the
wire so here's another one of these USB
wires and you take this USB wire and you
can plug in both blind spot integration
coming soon ah you can plug in both a
comma to end a black panda into your
Panda jungle and you can only unlock the
comma - with a comma key of course the
Panda uses a pan of pong it's all very
straightforward and clear
what does driver monitoring do it beeps
or does it tell you to pay attention to
the road it tells you it watches you and
if you're not paying attention it tells
you to look at the road and then if you
don't look at the road for long enough
it stops accelerating it's all level -
man it's all level - features over bug
fixes boo bug fixes over features yay
yeah we love fixing bugs fixing bugs is
our favorite thing to do to ever get a
ride one of the gimmicks cars no they
give me all right so you know maybe it
was a scam um yeah yeah yeah we'll get
we'll get those blind spot monitors
integrated that's gonna happen that's
still not gonna be autonomous lane
change it's just gonna block the lane
change if there's something in the blind
spot is the point fire will be released
- next week um do we have pipelines we
got big-ass pipeline in the garage yeah
do we support any trucks I think we
support the Honda Ridgeline is that a
truck yes it is a truck let's see I
think we support the new bridge line no
we don't support tank yeah
Oh check out my large Dunkin Donuts iced
coffee
obey or free doughnuts even better I
hate to eat dogs yesterday though no gas
pedal disengage will not be optional you
don't get out of here with that Tesla
beating hardware in 2020 I don't even
know what that means
surround monitoring with yeah it
functions dash cam it functions dash cam
it's all integrated with the common
connect app it's pretty nice when will
we get our L to actually work we're
using our out the new models you can
take the lanes out of them and they
still drive pretty well the internet
update is fixed in the dr650 zone five
I'm sorry about that it's fixed but
leave virtually Christus a Honda Civic
but I'm not sure about that you'll have
to ask him
yeah so we're coming close to three
o'clock where our great live stream one
discount code expires
it does work with a face mask with
sunglasses just us what hours do I work
non-stop
I heard elan name the baby influenza
musk how does it interact with the
heads-up display I mean I don't know
I've never used this in Ottawa thout I
used it very briefly with the stock
system and the stock system did some
weird stuff that I didn't understand and
then I put in well I didn't put it in be
great hard-working people of kamma put
it in and do I think Tesla could change
the AI approach of coma yeah maybe but
not everyone of that organizations on
board with that car Patti knows what's
up how many cameras did it have this two
cameras it's the comic - so it has two
cameras it has one camera right here
looking out at the road that's solid
driving camera what is my point of an
address get out of here and it has this
camera which watches you the driver
monitoring camera what is the new
product okay a new product is really the
real product that you're gonna want to
buy it's not like a super development
product is the human eye harnesses if
you know tie harnesses are for sale
right here there's five of them there's
gonna be more yonder harnesses than
other harnesses that's how crazy the
hyundai ecosystem is we're here we're
supporting it we got you there software
is pretty good pretty generic so yeah
check it out flat the wrong nobody cares
about you um guys I don't know I think
Hyundai is gonna be our top car soon
what is the coupon code do livestream
one you could save one dollar what
resolution you're asking the wrong
question it has way more resolution than
it needs we downsample the pixels you
want big pixels you don't need big
resolution so gonna be a new hardware
after you release the softball so this
is 1.0 hardware so we're gonna get the
comet to to go all the way to 1.0 this
is why like we have a one-year warranty
on this product you know the Aeons some
of them kind of broke especially if you
left them in the car
comma two should not break they're
really well tested so yeah this is 1.0
hardware so this is gonna be this is
gonna get us the 1.0 software
what's released except Hyundai harness
if you have a Hyun die you can get a
yunda harness what I merge with test
ah I thought about it a little but now a
new bundle of images you got to figure
out the old ones yeah chill for comet
10k if you guys want to go fill out
thingies go comet and cake who's
designing the hardware right here in
house we got an amazing hardware team
yoga describe you that's a great I love
this doesn't work in right hand drive
countries yes it does zero seven five is
going to support right hand drive it
actually puts in a bit to the model that
tells it yo stay on the other side of
the road we worked really hard on that
it's a toggle in the settings here I can
just paranoid on my Aeon let's go to my
e on here and right here you can just
toggle and it says enable right hand
drive that also makes the driver monitor
and look out the other side too so it's
pretty crazy
Hyundai harness is live W harness you
guys are always asking for the next
thing you know it may be a way be next
week we'll do the VW honest that mean I
was happy
um but yeah check this out yeah what
about 0.75 here right here just the neon
did I fix the metric system option was
it broken if it's broken yeah we'll
definitely fix it I don't know I don't
know was broken pencils going pretty
well that's come pretty well talking
about a new segment one of our car
manufacturers next to be included so let
me see the picture I have a picture
I don't know
oh yes
yeah here we go
so guys this here is all the supported
cars we support them all now every
single one in green we have at least one
model supported by the car and what's
wrong with the red and what's wrong with
the yellow who knows what's wrong with
yellow nope I don't even think Mahindra
is on this list actually I've never even
heard of them why our car harness is
$200 they're gonna be 300 soon so I'd
buy it at 200 be like damn now is a good
deal no what's wrong with the yellow
ones who knows what's wrong with the
yellow cars we have the link in the
Mazda and the Ford 10 second time out
exactly so those cars have timeouts so
you can't control the steering wheel for
more than 10 seconds at a time
what's wrong with the red ones who knows
what's wrong with the red cars
nope flex yes the red cars have flex
right no flex rate supports never gonna
happen so we've actually supported all
the cars that we can that's every that's
this is these are cars sold in America
that's like every brand
yeah the business is going to business
going crazy you know you guys saw most
of the sales numbers on Twitter
yeah so you guys remember you know
remember when I did that livestream
where we just like uh you know
complained about how terrible everything
was that was our sales numbers after
that how crazy is that i misspelled
jean-guy
medians right there um that i spelt it
right young died yeah yellow yellow cars
are weak no it's not even stock DM
what's light green versus dark green um
I think light green we don't actually
support any of them but there's no
reason we can't shun died Sunday I don't
know but yeah so yeah things are going
things are going really well
alright everybody hit that thumbs up
button on this YouTube video right now
can we get a hundred thumbs up well part
of it you go systems not open-source so
hardware is not open source because open
source benefit hardly a hundred and five
well that was so fast open source
hardware doesn't benefit 122 that's
crazy
124 um open source hardware doesn't
benefit anybody except for the you know
they're not gonna make herself not
really looking to help them out we're
looking to help you out you the
individual person car companies will
start to try to lock me out oh my god I
get this question all the time Apple
tried to lock me out so he tried to lock
me out and they tried real hard you
think you know this is this is the
signal it's in it's in it's in forgot
about Dre you know when he's talking
about his guns people running around
talking and saying [ __ ] about guns like
I ain't got none and what you think I
sold them all cuz I stay well off what
you think I forgot how to hack you think
they're gonna stop me nobody's gonna
stop me nobody's gonna stop , AI we are
unstoppable
we're actually I'm stoppable I mean you
know what I mean like they could shut
this whole thing down they could bring
this whole didn't bring this whole
building down they can put me in jail
and comma is unstoppable because open
pilots open software and you can't stop
the speech you can't stop the flow of
information oh yeah um what if they put
on Ford like lockout yeah but it would
also apply to them and that's the
problem and honestly could I figure out
how to reflash the fort yes do I care -
no it's for hire new people yeah well I
renew people there's building can fit 20
yr people get on coming and I slash jobs
apply can the model still work without a
radar almost we're so close
we're so close to 2r a darkness ah
Oh what if they gettin encrypted oh no
where they're gonna put the key oh the
key oh it's gonna be so hard to find I'm
gonna have to dig deep
can't I longitudinal support like next
one two months what about selling your
own powered steering to garages what you
can just buy it yourself it's super easy
to install it takes five minutes a
harness also open-source yetis things
are open-source we posted them all okay
guys thank you all for joining there's
never been a better time to join the
comment I e Co system how many can die
harnesses have been sold
same ones same ah oh no 660 on dialysis
yeah
how many suru zero there's no advising
Subaru can they make changes politically
yeah they can stop me but are they gonna
stop the the unlimited flow of comas
from China but you know there's no
reason to stop me you're here we're out
making driving better we're out making
driving safer we're out making driving
chill that's our slogan make driving
till does the warranty cover theft no
don't get your [ __ ] stolen um ask about
the window manager gonna get banned uh
we come in other countries ah no the
warranty doesn't cover you drop it no
you can't drop it but it covers
manufacturer defects if you have any
problem and you use it normally then um
we're happy to help you what is uh okay
all right all right
all right thank you all for watching
everybody go buy a Hyundai harness young
guys are the new officially supported
cars we support Honda's Toyota's young
guys and a whole bunch of other a kind
of unsophisticated I our Honda's
Toyota's and our latest yunda you think
I would build you did we build all these
harnesses if if we didn't care deeply
about Yan diet we do is the car list
online yeah commodore guys slash open
pilot check it out
know the training all the trainings all
closed source the trainings all secret
guys you know what about the training
like we could open source the training
and unless you have a
half-million-dollar supercomputer and
can't run any of it after myself i would
only benefit zooks and you know Zeus
[Music]
but comma whoo all right
no flexure will not give any profits
Fletcher is the biggest rabbit old
Fletcher is worse than Subaru no
actually those are really nice cars but
sorry we're not supporting flexor
Mahindra hi we're gonna look into this
Mahindra Colombo or whatever it is does
it work in UK yeah it works everywhere
now
we support right-hand drive so we got
everywhere on his Greyhound bus support
coming Subaru works so well but nobody
uses it because like guys think your
average Subaru driver think you're a bad
driver yeah now we're talking get into
Hyundai drivers today is a perfect day
to get in through the common community
and purchase stuff what happens 1
million Dajjal I will get there we'll
get there we'll get there all right
thank you all for watching
they'll never stop us yes
the driver monitoring field if you does
work with the right hand drive you don't
want to know beyond 500 tota well I hire
exuse employees absolutely yeah yeah um
yeah absolutely if you work to zukes and
you see the air on your ways nine six is
a cool company I should rip ones it's
too much good on them and putting those
videos out and I hope they uh you know
what you want to start being honest
about everything they put those videos
out where they have engineers talking
over an hour that's beautiful thank you
thank you that's being honest you want
to talk about your cruise origin on
stage get out of here get out of here
it's the current year we no longer
tolerate that [ __ ] a born Kensuke just
come to come join the winning team for
self-driving cars right here in good old
San Diego all right thank you all for
watching goodbye